[Music]
[Applause]
Robert Griffin III ESPN college football
NFL analyst and the winner of the
Heisman in 2011 when he played at Baler
where is the Heisman Trophy right now
well the Heisman Trophy is in my closet
right now for 10 years it was with my
mom and dad and uh we just recently got
it back with a bunch of moves going on
had to make sure it was Secure so I gave
it to the parents CU they helped me uh
accomplish all my goals and dreams so I
felt like it should be with them okay so
where are you going to display it in
your home uh in my home it'll still be
in the closet uh I'm not the guy that
that holds up a shrine to himself or
puts a bunch of trophies up and all that
if you if you really know me and you can
uh get to the closet then you'll get a
chance to see the hosman wow I mean is
it a walk-in closet is it you know big
closet clothes in there it's a it's a
big closet it's not like you know
shuttered or anything it's uh we double
double wooded the top of the of the
shelves to just be able to put any
awards that me and my wife as well she's
a you know Estonian heptathlete went to
Florida State um you know heptathlon
record holder there at Florida State so
we put all our trophies on the top and
that's the only way you'll get to see
them okay did your wife ask why Florida
state was not in the final
four yeah she she did but she um
she was pretty outraged about it as well
and then and so was I I thought the
committee certainly got it wrong and
sent the wrong message to all the fans
coaches and uh everyone out there that
follows the sport well okay is Florida
State better than
Georgia um according to the committee
they are do you think Florida state is
better than
Georgia the real question is did Florida
State earn a right to play in the
college football playoff and yes they
did that's the question well I think
that's open to interpretation because we
assume you go undefeated that means you
get to play it's it's open to
interpretation it's the human element
yes it is no it's not yes because
Florida State's not in the final four so
not open it's open it it was that's why
they're not the committee and I I
watched the show yesterday and heard you
talk to booger so um I know how you feel
about this and you feel like it's all
about the money it is but the question
for me is the college what is the
college football playoffs committees
selection committee what is their job
their job is to put the four best teams
in yeah correct it should be but that's
their job right should be okay so if
their job is to put the four best teams
in how are they breaking down the
criteria for what the four best teams
are it's the eye test for them I guess
they're we're not doing computers no
they're they're doing everything they
have the system set up so well that you
can't point to one thing to to say
gotcha that this is why they got it
wrong they're taking in conference
championships they're taking in the eye
test common opponents a whole bunch of
elements to determine who the four best
teams are so if you have these
Conference champions and they're all
similar because they're Conference
champions if one is undefeated from a
power five conference they've earned the
right to play in the college football
playoff period end of story We otherwise
otherwise now you're taking into account
your favor one conference over another
conference and if they're both
undefeated listen that that is open to
interpretation but when you have an
undefeated power five conference
Champion they have earned the right to
be in the college football playoff
because otherwise me and you could sit
here and make the argument that Georgia
should be in the college football
playoff because they were number one in
the committee's rankings for three
straight weeks and you're telling me
that a on loss Georgia wouldn't beat or
be favored against almost every team
that's in the college football playoff
yes they're not put the the four best
teams in they're not and in that case
what they did to Florida state is
completely wrong all right well we got
Georgia against Florida State right yeah
and how many guys do you think gonna opt
out of that well okay come on it might
be the opt that's all these bowl games
I'm looking at all these games these
matchups Robert right every team has
their quarterback in the portal yeah
it's bad it's bad there's 1,00 kids in
the portal yeah it's bad it's it's uh I
put it this way I've got two bowl games
uh and in both bowl games I think both
quarterbacks from both teams will not be
playing the game it's it's uh it's
utterly ridiculous from that standpoint
and I just had Marcus Freeman on my show
RG3 and the ones uh talking about you
know what's your what's your pitch to
The Players to actually play in this
game and it it all revolves around you
know standing by your brother there's
teams are going to ask hey why didn't
you play in this game and I think it's
it varies from like a first round guy if
you're going to be a top 10 pick and
you're not playing for a national title
I I understand um but there's going to
be so many opt outs of guys that are
going to be getting drafted fifth sixth
seventh round because they just don't
they don't see the reward in playing the
game uh based off the risk that that
there's going to be there uh and when
you talk about this Florida state
Georgia game it's it just goes back to
if Florida State without their
quarterback isn't better than Alabama or
Texas how in the they better than
Georgia but the committee put him in
front of Georgia and now we're GNA have
that game and some people are going to
use that game as barometer to say see
this is what happened but I I'm just I'm
going about this in a way that I don't
think that every player from Georgia or
every player from Florida State that led
to them getting to where they are right
now is going to play in the game it just
seem like it's going to happen Robert
Griffin II joining us uh on behalf the
more than a trophy campaign designed to
create greater awareness of the Char
able impact and uh the programs from the
Heisman trust beyond the annual Trophy
ceremony and uh his new podcast is RG3
and the ones anything you want to add to
more than a trophy campaign yeah Dan I
mean really the the Heisman Trophy trust
their their whole Focus right now is
just letting people know that they do
more than just hand out the Heisman
Trophy and me we got the humanitarian
award this year that's going to Solomon
Thomas from the New York Jets the
defensive end the trust has donated over
$25 million doll you know especially the
programs like the the high school
Heisman program that they have and for
me personally being able to work with
them you know since I won the award in
2011 uh has truly been a joy and and
they do so much in the community they've
helped me do so much in the community
giving back and and and helping with
food insecurity um that I felt like it
was it was very warranted to come on
here and not just sing their praises but
also be excited about the guys that we
have potentially coming to join that
Heisman fraternity uh I think they're
all worthy of the award talking about
Michael pennick Jr Jaden Daniels Bo
Nicks and of course Marvin Harrison Jr
out there playing like his daddy um it's
really cool to to see these guys have an
opportunity to to join this fraternity
and I look forward to the ceremony uh
coming up on Saturday who do you think
will
win that's a good that's a great
question Dan you know you've been in
this business a very long time so you
know I can't disclose my vote um but who
who do you think will win it doesn't
mean who you voted for who do you think
will win
you've been in the industry a long time
so you know how to answer the questions
um I think at the end of the day uh
collectively around the country you'll
see that Jaden Daniels probably um did
the most to to win the award uh passing
yards touchdowns all very similar to Bo
Knicks uh Michael pennick Jr led the
country in passing yards uh but it was
what Jaden Daniels did on the ground
rushing for 1,000 yards the only player
in college football to have 3,500 yards
passing and 1,000 yards rushing uh there
was just so much there and B Knicks I
feel like had an opportunity to win it
in the Pack 12 championship game but
because he got beat twice by Michael
pennick Junior uh there might be some
people that put a damper on that but I
could see it being a you know a blowout
race for jayen Daniels I could also see
it being very close because this year
there's a lot of worthy uh
finalists who turned in the greatest
season in your recent memory that a
quarterback
has what's the one that stands out more
than any yeah yeah I mean I think I know
where you're going with this for for me
it was probably Joe burrow the LSU year
that I just talked to him on the
sideline uh the Bengals Jags Monday
Night Football game um you know with his
injury we were talking about that year
they were just so dominant um and it's
just funny because Jaden Daniels had a
better year uh statistically than Joe
burrow did that season and we saw how
Joe burrow ran away with the Heisman
trophy so um it's uh it's one of those
deals of that it's pretty really
impressive year what Jaden Daniels did
but you look back um Manzel had an
unbelievable year uh you did
cam um I don't know who else you spring
you know burrow obviously in there
anybody else that you throw Caleb
Williams the year the previous one was a
great year by the way any problem with
him not playing in the bll
game uh I don't have a problem with
Caleb not playing in the ball game
um is that is that out there that he's
not playing I think so yeah okay so yeah
man I got no problem like I said I
called Kenny pickets game um when he had
the fake slide with Mark Jones and Quin
kesic and then we had their ball game
and Kenny didn't play in their bowl game
and we all understood why like there's
an opportunity there to go um you know
make generational wealth and I've got no
problem with Caleb not playing this year
in a bowl game because last year he
played in the bowl game when he wasn't
even 75% healthy so I think he's proven
that he's willing to put it all on the
line for for his guys and in this moment
if he is going to go pro and decides not
to play in that ball game then I don't
think anybody should hold that against
him we had Dan orlovi on first hour and
we were talking about structure in
college or lack of structure that Caleb
was wonderful out of structure but in
the
NFL you have to have structure yeah you
have to be able to at some point and you
know he wondered about that that he was
sort of out of structure cuz they had to
score 40 points you know maybe Lincoln
didn't say hey I need you to do this
like he had to improvise a lot that
transition from what you can get away
with college to what you can get away
with in the pros how big of a transition
is that for quarterbacks who are similar
athletically to
Caleb yeah I mean I think the the answer
to the question specifically is that the
windows in the NFL are Tighter and and
it's not just because the hash marks are
closer together uh it's because the guys
are bigger they're faster there's a
better understanding of how NFL defenses
are trying to attack an NFL offense now
do I think that that could be thrown off
100% it could be thrown off look at what
what Chip Kelly did with the Eagles in
his first year um it's just the concepts
in the NFL have become so repeatable
that if you've been in the league for
seven years you've seen every single
route Tree in combination that there's
known to man in those NFL offenses so
there are they're a little bit faster to
like understand things are happening and
there's no there's not as many fishes
what we call them on the field where you
go to into the game and you're like all
right this safety or this corner is the
worst player on the field we got to
attack him you know you're basically
attacking all Americans from college at
every stop that you go in the NFL so I
think that is a little bit of adjustment
for guys the game is a little bit faster
but I think it's a it's just simply a
talking point when guys bring up the
fact that Caleb Williams didn't play
Within structure I don't think that's
real I think what happens with Caleb
Williams is he goes through the
structure and then because he's so
Dynamic after the play breaks down that
is what we focus on so we see all the
Highlight re runs and the highlight real
scrambles but this guy does play Within
structure and he went to a Quarterback
Camp called the QB Collective which has
guys like the Cal shanahans and the Mike
McDaniels and the Shawn McVey and he
worked with them at a very young age and
I can tell you right now the NFL Scouts
and NFL coaches cannot wait to get their
hands on Caleb Williams they know he can
play with instructure they just love the
fact that he can be creative outside of
it Allah Patrick Mahomes you had world
class speed but let's look at Tyreek
Hill
speed how would you describe there's
fast and then fast guys looking at
somebody saying that guy's fast oh yeah
yeah yeah Tyreek is um he's uh he's
instant grits you know what I mean like
when as soon as he puts his foot down
he's at full speed and I think that's
the difference uh I appreciate you
saying that I have world class speed um
have world class speed uh but there's a
difference between like do you still
have world class speed yes I do there's
uh there's a difference between you say
bolt on a track uh having world class
speed and then being able to have that
translate on a football field if Usain
Bolt and Tyreek raced I certainly
believe that Usain Bolt is winning that
race but when you talk about being able
to run and cut and change direction and
catch the ball and get vertical and
break down and come out of your break
that's where just Ty
uh he sets himself apart from everybody
else in the league I just had him on the
show on RG3 and the ones and he was
talking about how he's trying to put on
for short Kings and he's doing that uh
there Tyreek Hills do not grow on trees
and because his ability as soon as he
puts his foot down he's at full speed
that's why you see DB so afraid to cover
him and they they really can't cover him
he has to make a mistake for them to be
able to cover him and I think we've seen
that this year as he's on Pace to you
know break that 2,000 yard barrier and I
think he should be the MVP right now
okay okay if I did a 60 yard dash yep
Tyreek Hill and Usain Bolt yep who
wins yeah I mean 60 yard dash you saying
bolts won in that race not right now I
don't know oh don't don't play don't
don't don't don't do that tyre and a 60
and a 60 and a 40 a 40 okay can he beat
him in a 40 in a 40 he has a chance okay
he has a chance but even on a track if
you put Tyreek in a 40 in comparison to
Usain Bol on a track
B wins that race there's a difference
between track speed and football speed
I'm telling you go look okay what if we
put him on the football field what if we
did yeah there's a video out there of
Usain Bolt running a 40 at like some
event maybe it was around the Super Bowl
or something and he in flats and he ran
like a four 4-1 so like don't get it
twisted all my people that are listening
right now understand I know the
difference between track speed and
football speed Tyreek kill is the
fastest human being that plays football
okay period end of story he's not faster
than Usain B did you reach out to the
Jets to try to play quarterback for them
you mean like Colin
Kaepernick I did not did I didn't do
that but but there are stories that
you've offered your
services
um oh no no no I haven't I haven't um I
personally have not reached out to a
team to say yeah as a representative a
representative reached out oh yeah I
mean Representatives reach out all the
time you know but they have to have your
approval no no they don't no no they
don't if if you have an agent if you
have an agent and someone's reaching out
to teams on on your behalf they don't
ask you if they can reach out to that
team they just reach out to the team so
what what I'll say is what I have done
is I have publicly stated that uh I can
play I'm willing and able to play I want
to play and if a team just so happens to
call my number I'll be ready to play I
have said that I said the Browns should
have signed me I thought they should
have they did went with Joe Flo guess
what Joe Flo looked really good this
past week for a guy that's just coming
off off the couch he looked really good
going out there playing and I'm sure the
Jets wish they had Joe Flo right now
yeah or Zack Wilson because they need
him back badly okay what do you make of
the Zack Wilson situation here how does
this happen robertt it's so funny man I
I will say this Aaron roders is 100%
right when he talks about the sources in
the building going out there and trying
to undercut Zack Wilson now that is
completely wrong uh I'm sure Rogers has
experienced it at some point in his
career I certainly did that's not what
winning organizations do so I agree with
him on that for the Zach Wilson thing to
me it was hilarious watching the clip of
him and Aaron on the sideline because uh
it definitely looked like Aaron said
something along the lines of yeah and
they thought you were the problem when
you get someone else out there and you
now cut the guy that you benched Zack
Wilson for and are now starting another
guy yeah I mean it it it was clear to me
and I've said it it wasn't all on Zack
Wilson they only started the other guys
because they felt like they had to do
something now they're saying that Zach
Wilson is the best quarterback they have
on the team that's healthy and they need
to start and he and he should play and I
don't think that he's shying away from
wanting to play it's just a matter of
the team having his best interest at
heart and that's I think the the real
point and booger brought this up they've
quit on him
yeah like they kicked him to the Cur put
him in let him play Let him play the
rest of the Year Tim Bole is not an NFL
quarterback he just not might be great
in the quarterback room Trevor Simeon is
not a starting quarterback if if we're
going to find out about Zach Wilson
let's find out now you're going to find
out more about him than you will at any
other point in his life in his career
when he's down now let's see what you
got throw him in there let him go good
or bad he's not going to be with the
team next year feels like some coaches
are covering up for themselves trying to
protect themselves that it's Zach
Wilson's the issue not
them man it's a strong statement and
then I don't disagree with it at all I
think two reasons they need to start
Zack Wilson one he's the best
quarterback they have that is clear and
evident and he's the most talented
quarterback that they have and at this
point like you said his response what do
you do when when you're completely
backed into a corner but you literally
have nothing to lose you will be here
next year yeah go out there let that dog
hunt and I mean would you say the jet
season is over right now yeah then they
have nothing to lose putting Zack Wilson
back out there let him go play and and
and put him in the best position to be
successful throw let him let him throw
the ball 45 times I don't know they
can't run it so you might as well let
him go out there and be a gunslinger and
see what he can show the rest of the
league great to talk to you always thank
you hey appreciate you Dan God bless
it's Robert Griffin Jr II part of the
Heisman trust the more than trophy
campaign also his podcast RG3 and the
ones